claudio yo yo yo yo yo 10 dei ragazzi
oggi il giorno specialissimo perché mi
hanno finalmente procurato il trailer
i social dream non avendo mai visto
nulla del montaggio finale di social
dream che il nostro docufilm quello che
ho fatto quindi messa sabrina non avendo
ancora visto nulla oggi che è uscito il
trailer di social dream
lo vedremo insieme perché io non l'ho
mai visto e ci farò appunto la reaction
perché è un momento epocale visto che lo
aspettiamo da secoli e per l'occasione
deciso anche di vestirmi in modo film
perché andiamo comunque per chi non lo
sapesse e social dream è un film o
meglio un documento documento blogging
blog mentario che hanno girato seguendo
meimei sabrina facendo vedere un po come
la nostra vita da youtuber dietro le
quinte e in giappone nelle nostre case è
questo film dopo film documentario
uscirà su sky tra pochissimo e ve lo
faremo sapere probabilmente la data
adesso vediamo il trader
tutti quanti quindi ragazzi abbiamo il
trailer il computer ha gentilmente
concesso da lorenzo mi ricordo quando
abbiamo fatto queste riprese quindi non
so del risultato finale del trailer
parlo ovviamente quindi sono super è
gasato per sta cosa non attendiamo un
secondo di più
let's go
quindi in viaggio ha saputo dividere il
credo del dire il nostro evitando lavoro
lavoro lo sapevo intervento non è ancora
la squadra è pronta a mio agio nei
[Musica]
addio con in giappone che casino
riguarda il giappone una meta
ambitissima per i gamer tegola la terra
promessa del videogiocatore e spippoli
continua e basta con questo mio commento
lo considera il meraviglioso
per fare questa cosa delle andare in
bici dentro il centro commerciale ci
abbiamo messo ne sono fregato sotto
stato
wow perché in giappone di mazzola non
sai mai cosa del genere
io faccio la parte del bambino non so se
sono andato a quello che sta nella bici
quello che fa le bolle
ok
[Musica]
abbiamo passato delle giornate
indimenticabili ero assolutamente auto
molto bene per capelli magnate palladino
sempre va da sé che il libro il titolo
al mezzo giapponese è fighissimo
comunque ragazzi la cosa molto molto
bella è che questo film docu film
documentario è una che non c'è un
copione ovviamente ci hanno ripresi
mentre facevamo cose normali sono
ripresi per tre mesi e per tre mesi noi
abbiamo avuto queste videocamere che ci
seguivano non vedo né sapevate nulla
proprio perché questo progetto e gigante
e quindi non c'è ovviamente un copione
nel nulla
secondo me è uscita una cosa incredibile
adesso non sono curiosissimo di vedere
anche il film perché ovviamente non è
ancora uscito già il trailer è veramente
figo ragazzi non lo so però secondo me
potrebbe veramente se un lavoro
incredibile
prepariamo non piangere in sala
proveremo non piangere però vedendo io
che vado in bicicletta dentro il centro
commerciale giapponese un po da piangere
ci sarà quindi ragazzi che se finiamo
qui più avanti usciranno un sacco di
news e ve le faccio sapere magari
tramite in staino che tutto il resto
presso continuiamo con il blog ho voluto
sganciare questa bomba a teniamo lì
perché al piano esplode e passiamo
adesso ai blog ho fatto una challenge
con gabry ponte ma verrà spiegato vesco
allora ragazzi
mi spiego un pochettino di cosa si
tratta questo progetto questo disco
dalla me è stato e nasce da un'idea di
ha reso tonic hanno partecipato danti
jade e jake la furia mettendoci la voce
e voi potrete partecipare per dare un
aiuto a questa causa noi abbiamo deciso
di devolvere tutti i proventi di questo
disco in beneficenza serviranno per
realizzare con l'aiuto di amref dei
pozzi per portare le popolazioni
dell'africa
quindi anche voi ascoltando
semplicemente del disco potete dare un
contributo a questa causa è una canzone
contro lo spreco quindi volevamo
lanciare questa challenge che si che va
di moda allora abbiamo fatto invasione
nel canale di far vincere in pena allora
questa challenge gl consiste nel bere un
bicchierino d'acqua ultimo parto sono
moriano utenza usarli e senza sprecare
senza sprecare la quindi senza cercare
non pagherei neanche una goccia
ok dove siamo siamo studenti margini di
gocce negato anno a prescindere però
biancoazzurro le genti
il messaggio pista e non è neanche
delfino maniera di girare quando stai
hanno coinvolto in una trappola così
neanche arancio liberale
e poco va bene iniziamo che per dovere
piccolo sbaglio ma cosa pensa mamma
questo
valenti si trova bene
tutto in realtà la difficoltà che muore
affogato meta è la pelle challenge son
fatto non sono fatto metà grazie gabri
non l'hai sprecata lungo la e
riutilizzata malissimo
voi non dovete fare come famiglie è
semplicissimo lo scalpo della challenge
questo fatelo anche voi mettete lo nelle
storie con la canzone sotto e poi
taggate tra i vostri amici che che
sfidate a fare questa challenge e chi ci
riesce con chi vince avrà avrà fa vj a
casa sua
bagnato la rivincita di farisei che
mirino a te ne mettono veramente poca
ancora più difficile di fermo è malato
avevo mai detto no no no no va bene va
bene va bene si è facilissimo dai la
roba veramente la spogliarellista ma non
so come ho fatto ma l'ho fatto ho vinto
un file
e già sprecato nella mischia ma neanche
parlare si possono immaginare che
denuncia
ti sei mai bye bye bye abbiamo capito lo
ha fatto
però la gente guarda non ti resta
comunque mirino di fare dice
[Musica]
però l'intenzione che tale fenomeno non
avevo mai provato a me comunque
riuscirci o non riuscirci non è
importante l'importante è partecipare la
cella infatti del bene e raccomanda una
nobile causa
basti portate capri quanti e questa
causa case a tutti il avere grandissima
questa challenges and dream a te la
canzone riportare le storie e taggati c
e non sprecare l'acqua va dalla roma
mazza che settimana allora sono stanco
perché e venerdì sera ho finito la mia
settimana ho girato tante cose lunedì
barra martedì
vedrete una cosa molto speciale su
youtube non sul mio canale però la
vedrete non sapete di cosa sto parlando
sarà una cosa epocale tranquilli ve lo
assicuro per questo cosa mi sono anche
vestito così quindi va dice tutta c'è
un'altra cosa che volevo dirvi prima di
concludere è che io in sei anni ho
sempre registrato con questa roba fano
questo schifo di webcam che ha una
qualità veramente dei miei piedi
registrano meglio che se no perché
voglio di che fa schifo brough 5 milioni
iscritti quasi 5 mila iscritti ho voluto
spendere dei soldi io maledetto braccino
tirchio ho speso dei soldi per
incrementare la qualità video e adesso
non register o più con questa ma dietro
questa splendida videocamera e c'è
webcam è comparsa ta ta ta ta la
videocamera fissa che ho attaccato al
muro
questo qua attaccata io infatti non si
smuove sono proprio un bravo saldatore a
questa roba qua si vede da dio quindi
riuscirete a contar mi i peli del culo
quando registrerò emilio dalla prossima
settimana perché video di questa
settimana
gli ho già registrati ringrazio tutti i
partecipanti a questo logo è stato
veramente diciamo fatto un biglietto di
cose sta settimana ha fatto al romics ha
fatto il games week mi ci siamo
divertiti in tutte e due le fiere come
non mai è stato bellissimo questa
settimana che arriva ci saranno altri
casini vi ripeto non avete idea di che
cosa ho appena registrato oggi quindi
tranquilli come sempre ragazzi spero che
vi sia più
come al solito se video è piaciuto un
momento non mi piace anche per i social
che come vi dò tutto nella scrizione se
non sono recisi iscrivetevi
ci vediamo a un prossimo video molto più
in hd di come lo sono mai stati fino
adesso dai ragazzi
[Musica]
no